حرب المسيرات هكذا يصف المراقبون الصراع
الدائره في اوكرانيا وعلى هذا الاساس وجهت
كييف قدراتها للحصول على هذا السلاح باكبر
كميه ممكنه 200 الف هذا عدد المسيرات التي
تسعى الحكومه الاوكرانيه لشرائها بحلول
نهايه العام هذا الكم الضخم سيتم انتاجه
محليا حيث ان 30 شركه محليه تنتج المسيرات
المطلوبه وقد تم توقيع عقود مبدئيه لفي
وحده لاسابيع قليله حيث تتم زياده الاعداد
المطلوبه كل فتره هناك حاجه الى المسيره
بكل انواعها وبقدرات مختلفه من اجهزه
الاتصالات كلما زاد عدد المسيرات التي في
حوزتنا زادت قنوات الاتصال وبذلك يصبح
عملنا اكثر كفاءه
الاوكرانيون يستخدمون مسيراتهم داخل
اراضهم للدفاع ولكن كذلك للهجوم
حيث استخدموا الطائرات بدون طيار لضرب
محطه ال سكي لتكرير النفط في منطقه كوبانا
المسيرات تسمح لقوات كييف بالحاق الضرر
بروسيا فقد وصلت الى الكرملين في هجوم لم
يلحق ضررا كبيرا بمقر الرئاسه الروسيه
ولكنه شكل ضربه قاسيه للدب الروسي امام
انظار العالم
انس نماسي العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات